oh good good morning I'm wanna before
starting I want to say I'm sorry that I
can't participate more in this I really
have many friends old and new here and
I'm teaching three classes and you know
so it's just monday wednesday and friday
and it's just my fault but it's also
true so I've I want to talk about a
class of problems that well I am working
on and I've heard about it and you all
hear about it if you ever talk to
anybody not in this community but who
actually does simulations when i first
started thinking about card shuffling i
talked to a friend the physicist and I
said you know how many times he have to
shuffle the deck of cards to mix it up
and he said well it depends what game
you're playing and and I said no no no
okay so we have settled on global
measures of convergence but very often
when people run markov chains they don't
care about all features they care about
whatever they're running their markov
chain for the magnetization in the Ising
model and the fact that this or that
does or doesn't converge good for you
and so chemists and physicists talk
about things they say sentences like
well yeah those are the slow modes but
we don't care about that it's the local
features and they equilibria much faster
so i have wanted to try to make sense
out of that and just to say a simple
example to keep in mind so i call
features and I you'll see what i mean
but and what i have in this talk is a
bunch of examples that I which will
remind us that that this is an area and
then some sort of unifying thoughts but
mostly that's it's open problems so
consider
a simple random walk a simple random
walk on CP the integers might pee and
piece of prime just to not have any
problems 0 up to P minus 1 and you know
it's the plus or minus 1 walk on on this
guy there are people around the circle
drunkards walk and so suppose in this
toy problem you were running your walk
to estimate the size of a set which is a
thing which is done a fair amount and
well if the set a is the even numbers 0
2 4 6 etc just every other number around
the circle you get random lightning fast
any finite number of steps will do yeah
and so and if you want to if you want to
math the quantification of that the
probability that xn your walk at step in
starting from zero is contained in a
minus a half that's what the measure
would be i'm thinking of p as being
large is less than or equal to literally
less than or equal to e to the minus
minus and over to that's that's actually
true and so um you know with n is 10 or
however you know i mean you know this
gets random very very fast okay but if a
if a is equal to the bottom half of the
circle I won't here's a the bottom half
of the circle it takes you p squared
steps to get random you have to wrap
around a lot of course right I mean I'm
not saying anything but if a is equal to
the bottom half it takes order P squared
steps necessary and sufficient so that's
a simple example and of course this is a
toy example but in
no I don't have a parity problem with p
is a prime did you come late i said pisa
prime there's no parity problem of pisa
prime whole house young and if you
really he is large and if n is 10 this
bound is if n is any growing number and
p is large i could put in those kaval
sorry grow up you know that is if i do
ran if p is large and if i do random
walk and I'm trying to ask to make the
even numbers any growing number of any
growing number of steps it's close to
random so if you don't want to argue
with that oh come on I mean okay so that
that that is just an example to keep in
mind and so what I want to do is talk
about some some examples I want to get
as good a way of communicating as i can
so i'll keep trying these until i get
one that I'm that I'm happy with and
let's see so the the set of examples
where a lot is known it's just there are
lots of examples and to see what kinds
of differences there are so example for
riffle shuffling and the usual model of
you cut the cards about in half and you
go according to the Gilbert Shannon
reads model I won't say more about that
we showed with Dave fire on all this the
two that three halves log to the base
two of n plus C steps but this is the
operon
part of it or necessary and sufficient
to get roughly e to the minus C close
too close to randomness in total
variation so let me not let me not write
that down more carefully but suppose you
care about features for example in this
I'm giving for extra talks this week the
one on Tuesday was for the casino
security conference in vegas which had
700 people who don't didn't look like
you they had suits on for example and
many of them had broken noses and so
they don't they say listen you know in
blackjack and baccarat the suits don't
matter and the the tens jacks queens and
kings all are the same there are tens
and so maybe fewer shuffles or suffice
and so that's an hour math question
that's a feature and how how long does
it take if that's all you care about and
so let me go through some of the things
that we know these are just examples to
remind you so if if you just care about
the red black pattern so for reds and
blacks i'll write it this way and there
are fancier versions of it but log to
the base two of n plus c there's a cut
off and see but this three-halves
changes to changes to to a one in front
of the log to if you care about
randomizing the top card only so you
start you know know if you start with
the ace of spades on top you want to
randomize the ace of spades so i'll
write ace of spades but i mean the card
which is originally on top it's the same
number of steps and that's a little
surprising the the number of things i
want to get random in with reds and
blacks is 2n choose n it's a big space
where is the number of things i want to
get random with on the ace of spades is
just a single card and yet it takes the
same
a number of steps necessary and
sufficient to get random so something to
think about perhaps more interesting in
a certain sense is if you want to
randomize the top card that's different
that is I care about what card is on top
now after shuffling okay that takes a
half log in so somebody understands that
I be that meets a theorem but log to the
base two of n as long as I'm well I
skipped if you some time we did the
length of the longest increasing
subsequence I'll write L of pie so
that's a famous feature and suppose you
care about that feature it's 56 log to
the base two of n the number of descents
just the descent pattern the up-down
pattern in the permutation the sense is
one half log to the base two of n and
again plus C and I'll continue over here
and I'll stop soon it's not that I've
run out of features that we know about
but if you care about the cycle
structure how many fix points how many
transpositions how many three cycles the
entire cycle structure okay the entire
cycle structure so psycho structure
it's any growing number C of n so that
is log log log n if n is large I'm any
growing number the entire cycle
structure is random if you care about
just the Lord cycles for example the
length of the longest cycle in a random
permutation is about point 6 3 n the
long cycles the longest cycle long
longest cycle the answers 1 after one
riffle shuffle if n is large the the
distribution of the length of the
longest cycle matches the the
distribution and a random permutation so
these are some examples of features now
there is a handout and I don't know
let's try is there well I have it all in
memory there is a handout and so there
are some some numbers there and let me
well I the most surprising set of
numbers are the second block of numbers
so let me take you through that because
that's very very surprising to me both
intuitively mathematically I don't
understand that that's work of Conger
and Howland and there's a reference in
the handout thank you person and so
these are total variation results and
they're gotten by various ways
asymptotics and and very very
sophisticated computing and i mend their
paper but let me take you through a
little bit of this so this is this table
and the the first row is in total
variation distance to uniformity for
riffle shuffling in the skill Bert
Chanin reads model the only thing that's
a little strange is a is 2 to the K if
if I'm doing k shuffles they're using my
notation so I shouldn't complain but so
a sixteen is four shuffles five shuffle
six shuffles seven shuffles that's that
128 is that okay with everybody so the
first row you can see there the numbers
from the work I did with Dave buyer and
the
our exact numbers we know them to 70
base places of rational arithmetic and
they have an approximation and I'm going
to come to some of those approximations
and their approximation isn't great when
with a small number of shuffles by the
time you get to seven shuffles their
approximations pretty good and then it
gets better and better and closer and
closer as as time goes on but that first
row is just to say you know after seven
shuffles the total variation distance is
about point you know point three three
and and then then it cuts down and goes
exponentially fast 20 okay so what
they're doing is a different kind of
feature and let me try to explain that
bridge is a standard game with 52 cards
in which there are four hands of 13
cards dealt out now bear with me for a
second first let's take the stupid way
of dealing so stupid dealing which is
you take the top 13 cards you give them
to the South player you to the first
player you take the next 13 cards you
give them to that you just take consumed
nobody deals that way but if the cards
are mixed up it doesn't matter at all
right so just suppose you did that
that's a way of dealing okay you could
now it doesn't it the order within that
hand doesn't matter so you don't care
about all 52 factorial arrangements
being equally likely you just care that
the bridge hands have the right
distribution so that's a feature it's
just the group acting on the other side
we'll come to that but you know it
should be less shuffles okay and it is a
little bit less if you look the the
total variation distance to uniformity
is you know so instead of being point 33
it's point 22 or whatever it is it's a
little it's your clothes are slightly
closer that's if I do dumb dealing okay
suppose now I do the normal way of
dealing okay so I find this shocking
somebody has an idea great
one-two-three-four one-two-three-four
just steal around that way how could it
make any difference
take a look you're not looking good we
should be so take a look at the at the
it's north south east west of the 13th
and what you see is it's about a factor
of 10 closer okay so it's actually a
factor of 13 closer how could that be
what's going on and it's really
interesting and seems to be true now and
this again for me shocking here's a
strange way of dealing a 1 2 3 4 4 3 2 1
1 2 3 4 4 3 2 1 just do that okay it's
faster by another factor of 10 okay I
believe this this is true it's very
carefully done by the team of people
wherever I could check anything it's
right there not theorems that it's based
on both simulation and an approximation
which match but it is seems to be the
case that features can make a difference
okay that's that's what I yes sir these
days don't buy machine most you know I
mean who says that you are just now but
it's not true in in tournament play in
tournament play that's true but
certainly not most bridge hands are not
tournament play and have nothing to do
with the computer club bridge in Europe
anyway
use machine shuffling and I don't know
what I feel they is I I do and so I did
consulting for the bridge league and and
at first they used random transpositions
not carefully that is they did random
transitions and they did 60 of them and
it was quite was quite far now they use
the the usual random number generator
that's I'm talking about in tournament
play in the American clubs but that's
not relevant to this particular
conversation it's another one so let me
let me cut it off right I I'm happy to
take it at the end Martin but it is not
not to do with features right it's a
it's a so grow up is large then the
issue is whether you walk to the
positive or the negative but there's an
error of one of the root end from the
possibility that you get back to zero
rather than rather than go positive or
negative to the error the P large is
over order one of the root and rather
than the minus n over 2 okay that's fine
but still it's true that any growing
number of shopping I singled I see that
that's the that that's thank you okay
that that is the chance that if you flip
a fair coin end times that it comes up
even right but that's not what's written
there that's that's true too okay fair
enough fair enough good thank you good
so a question now arises obviously from
this kind of development there are a lot
of features that might be interesting
and how do you make any sense out of
this and and their various reasons for
thinking about that if you're a senior
person like some of us it's you know you
might have infinitely many papers to
referee somebody just takes some other
random
and so how do you make some sense out of
that what's an example of a sort of
sensible bringing together of that and
so I want to talk about one of those and
that's this thing that Sammy us often
sound origin and I did called the rule
of thumb so the rule of thumb and that's
still about card shuffling and so it's
looking at the following kind of
features suppose that I have n cards and
I have di of type I 1 1 less than or
equal to i less than or equal to M so
maybe it's reds and blacks maybe it's
you know clubs hearts spades and
diamonds it's it's the I just I only
care about about this kind of feature
for example for blackjack and back at
blackjack and baccarat the one might be
equal to D 2 equals d 9 is equal to 4
and the 10 is equal to 16 if I got it
right so that that's a that's a possible
there's nothing they don't have to be
balanced in any way but you just have
different types of cards that you care
about and in order to state a theorem I
I need to assume that di is bigger than
or equal to 3 okay but I mean so it
doesn't cover the ace of spades and let
me not try to make up this result then
we worked in separation which is so the
separation after k shuffles is the
maximum in call it W of 1 minus the
probability starting from wherever you
started from that you're in w-well /
a stationary probability of W so 1 minus
no no absolute values just 1 minus that
so look at the ratio or the after being
after Keysha steps look at the chance
that you're at w after k steps look at
the stationary distribution after k
steps take that ratio take the
subtracted from one take the take the
maximum of that so that's an upper bound
for a total variation and it's it's a
lower bound within a factor of two in a
certain sense but anyway it's a it's a
reasonable notion of distance students a
little easier to work with and here's
our theorem oh I'll write it here the so
cept k so I'm in this situation I've
shuffled the I'm doing ordinary riffle
shuffle zor though that model of riffle
shuffle sep k is equal to well it's
there's a formula but let me write it
down 1 minus 1 plus ADA it is going to
be tiny times 2 to the K times M minus 1
divided by n plus 1 and plus M minus 1
unfortunately it goes on a little bit
there's a single some j equals 0 to M
the number of types alas alternating
minus 1 to the J in let me get that
right M minus 1 choose J so it's
something Guan minus J over 2 to the K
that's the number of shuffles and the
exponent here is n plus M minus 1 okay
so there's some formula and ADA which is
tiny is less than or equal to 1 plus n
squared over 3 times 2 to the k plus M
us one squared and then this is all
raised to the M minus 1 power except
this bracket minus 1 so impossible to
parse but the the point of it is the
following I can't say it but that there
are several points to make about this
formula first of all for reasons that we
try to explain in the paper it's
amazingly accurate that is it's provable
and you can check how big a des is but
it's more accurate than we can prove so
it's accurate to sort of seems to be
accurate to five in six decimal places
and for ends that matter for deck sizes
that matter so and then I can't say it's
law again I mean I can in some instances
but it's this but this is trivial to
compute you know it's just a single some
and so we can compute it and that's
where the numbers on the top bracket
come from and so I want to take you
through that but points to be noted
about this is or that it doesn't it
doesn't depend on the the details of the
D eyes in any way that is it's true just
it's true that is for very very general
you know just doesn't doesn't depend on
very much and that's how many that's how
many shuffles or that's what that's what
the separation is and just to look a
little bit so to help you look at
separation some people like that I do so
the top row is the results from the work
with Dave buyer that is that's the exact
separation and so you can see after
seven shuffles the separation still one
but you know by 11 shuffles it's a half
and then it goes down by factors of 2
that's just the way that's the way those
numbers go once they start going down
they go down by factors of 2 and that
keeps going forever that's a theorem for
a blackjack
well you know the it's smaller after you
know 11 shuffles it's a factor of you
know four or five smaller and and if you
care about suits it's smaller still if
you care about the ace of spades the
original top card it's it's it's smaller
still the ace of spades and the red
black pattern oh it seemed to be the
same and maybe somebody can understand
that some day and the bottom row is on
parapsychology experiments they use 25
cards which are five different symbols
each repeated five times and I have a
long time fascination with debunking
parapsychology research and and so I I
did those numbers anyway that's an
example of of what a general you know
how you would make how you would break
away from doing examples one at a time
I'm going to come back a little bit and
talk about techniques for proof but this
is an example of how you could make a
general a general statement yes that's
the point they'd go that they they don't
the this this we notice that they all
cancelled out so I mean they they don't
cancel out but they we were able to
prove a theorem for all the eyes now for
aldi is bigger than or equal to 3 right
so it's surprising it's interesting that
the point I'm trying to make is there's
interesting math to be done for this
class of problems that is unifying in
some way I mean that that's but that's
the point I'm trying to make I'm not
particularly trying to sell this result
even though it's a it's a nice result
now one thing I know is that there is an
eraser and it's often stuck on the
on the boards that's it thank you so
sure this is the worst starting to
finish not just that goes max / w is
saying no no no it's the where am i
where are we here that no this is this
actually doesn't depend on the starting
but you have the DS you have these types
the dividend does matter true sure so
when I talk about how we prove things
out I'll address that and if I don't get
me as some people have but but of course
right so maybe well there's no let me
let me address that right now because
there's no reason to okay so let me say
how this result is proved in outline and
so there are three steps to proving this
kind of theorem usually to proving
something about separation so outline
proof step one you have to figure out
what's the worst-case configuration so
what you store which is the maximizing
and so for example and these are little
theorems if you start with the reds and
blacks if you start with all the Reds on
top and all the blacks under then the
worst-case provably is all the Reds on
the bottom and all the blacks on top so
that's a little theorem if you start
with the ace of spades on top the worst
case is the ace of spades on the bottom
so they're all little combinatorial
facts and you've got to do them and and
we are able to do that for for for this
general type it's not always so simple
and they're there there'll arguments
that's the first thing you have to do so
the second thing you have to do that's
what makes life easier is that you have
to figure out what this is so and let me
I did an example I wrote down an example
so the second step in proving is you
have to figure out what's p store k of w
store your you're the chance of being at
your worst case configuration and after
after w store half the w star sorry
after k steps and for reds and blacks
this is equal to in the case of reds and
blacks so there's a formula and it was 1
over 2 to the K times 2n this is a deck
of 2n cards and reds and n blacks times
a single some j equals 1 to 2 to the K
minus 1 of 2 to the K minus J to the n J
to the N minus J minus 1 to the N period
ok so there's nice combinatorial Smith
to do in in trying to derive formulas
for you know you have a specific thing
and then these are I mean so that's a
second thing some miracle that you can
do these the formulas for general dr
more complicated but not so much more
complicated that we couldn't write them
down and the third thing is you do
calculus i mean so and and so you take
this thing and we some of us like
massaging expressions of that sort and
so is that that is my attempt to answer
your question so I of course it matters
how you start and write the reason that
is it naively it appears like there
should be some sort of duality between
what you talk about in this second table
yes they are they are duels as a group
acting on the right and acting on the
left right it it should that's true but
I didn't know the dealing is just funny
something yeah shuffle certainly not
reversible but Markov chains aren't
reversible so the so that
will let me conclude my my shuffling
example I just wanted you to see there
you know there's a little subject there
and and there are many other things to
do in our world but this is one of them
and I want to talk about one more
example of features which I find
interesting in which I don't know how to
abstract and so that's a so this is just
a new example and it's a simple random
walk on the Heisenberg group let me
start with that one so so I guess I call
at you three of P is a set of all three
by three matrices which go like that
where x y and z are in the mod p so in
FP and so i'll write such a i'll write
such a matrix as XYZ and if you multiply
matrices well you know X Y Z times X
prime Y prime Z prime is X plus x prime
y plus y prime z plus z prime plus XY
prime if I got it right you just
multiply the matrices so this is called
a Heisenberg group mod p & o the walk I
want to do is based on the minimal set
of generators s my generating set is
plus or minus 1 0 0 or 0 plus or minus
10 and that's it so it's four generators
and Q of I don't know M is you know one
quarter if M is contained in essence 0
otherwise and so this war corresponds to
you start at the identity matrix and you
pick a row at random and you add or
subtract it from the row above it that's
it's just row operations that's that's
what this more corresponds to and early
on i don't know how many years ago with
with Soloff cost we show
ode that p squared steps are necessary
and sufficient for total variation
mixing so i'll just write it p squared
steps are necessary and sufficient for a
total variation mixing and there's no
cut often so okay and we have sharp
upper and lower bounds but okay and so
for years i wanted to know and I think
Aaron Smith is here and i tortured him
trying to know it too but i finally
tortured Bob Huff into actually doing it
I wanted to know how this one three
coordinate behaves and just seemed to me
that it would get random faster and with
Bob Huff we we proved that the the third
coordinate the central coordinate the
z-coordinate takes p steps necessary and
sufficient and and ok and now so i hope
well i'll say a sentence about methods
for for this too in a second but so
features can get random faster I'm you
know we've been saying that all time and
now let me do a higher dimensional
version if I fix d fix a dimension fix d
say five or some fix d and i look at you
d p which is just d by d matrices 11 11
10 and then star stars in FP so in the
same walk just you know the same analog
of the walk pick a row at random and i
had to subtracted the row above it
again with Soloff costs we showed that p
squared steps is necessary and
sufficient for a total variation on the
full group but now the work that we we
work quite hard to prove this is we can
break this apart and see the probability
waves coming in so the just above the
diagonal on the first diagonal that this
is the main diagonal the first diagonal
you just look at an entry on the first
diagonal or role of them because D is
fixed the first diagonal p squared steps
necessary and sufficient and on the
second diagonal p steps second diagonal
p steps on the third diagonal p to the
two third steps and on the case diagonal
it's it's p to the two over cake and so
thank you thank you right it's very
helpful no no keep trying so what can
people parse this or understand what I
just said that is as you go further and
further up you get you get closer and
closer to random this is important what
time is it okay good good so the to say
one sentence about the method of proof
in this case
it's hard that's my sentence but if I
write these steps as if if I write
epsilon delta 0 for which of these four
which of these four steps so epsilon
Delta will either be you know plus or
minus 1 0 0 or 0 plus or minus 10 okay
just write it that way then the walk the
the Z coordinate the Z coordinate is is
equal to you can just write it out it's
epsilon epsilon i think it's d minus 1
times delta 1 plus delta d minus 2 plus
epsilon D minus 2 times Delta 1 + and so
on plus Delta D minus 3 and on down to
epsilon 2 Delta 1 so mod mod p but so
essentially these epsilon and Delta more
or less independent of each other and so
one can write the thing that we one
wants to get one's hands on as a kind of
standard probability some of something
like iid random variables and then we
blasted out a careful local limit
theorem with a barrier scene type
remainder in order to study this mod p
we did it over Z and then study that mod
mod p so and if you if you look k above
instead of having quadratic sums you
have K fold iterated things but they're
similar the work is quite hard it used
so-called higher Fourier analysis the
kind of stuff that green tau and company
have been selling to the world and it
was it was it was hard honest work but
it's again it's a there's a kind of
unifying picture of some sort and okay
so so what are some questions well
going backward I'd love to know what
what I was doing here that is a it's
perfectly natural to choose coordinates
for a group in a matrix representation
but if you want to try to say if you do
this on groups of order P to the N pick
a group that you're interested in of
order p to the n then you know the
integers mod p wreaths the integers mod
p versions of lamplighter type groups
and if you try to think what's the
analog of these of these layers that I'm
looking at I don't know how to abstract
this okay that's one sentence so maybe
somebody can think of it's something
like going down the lower central series
of the group but it's not that is the
look the quotients aren't quite like
that so I don't I don't know how to
abstract that a i should say here you
know you've all an alan sly that a very
nice piece of work where d & p are
allowed to grow together and my results
are for fixed d in large p it would be
interesting to you know to see what
happens if dnp grow together just as the
last sentence to say or making a
connection i gave this talk in Haifa and
Yuval was there and at the end of it he
said you know this work is very very
close to the work on boolean functions
and having now worked at Rio Donald's
six hundred and some-odd page book
wonderful book it's certainly true that
is this a connection between the kinds
of questions I'm asking and take your
feature a function of set and expand it
in a basis of eigenfunctions and then
see you know can you get your hands on
the coefficients of the expansion and
eigenfunctions and in the wonderful
hypercube which is as appealing in that
group as there is an awful lot of the
work in boolean function
theory work that al-quran and others
have been instrumental in doing is
getting bounds on those on the Fourier
coefficients of interesting sets sets
like majority and other sets and all of
that can be translated into if you care
about this feature of the walk it gets
random at this rate and there is a
little list to be made of the type that
I made for the shuffle group that would
come from all of the hard work in that
community a an issue is you know if you
care about real Markov chains good luck
for you to you getting your hands on the
eigenfunctions you know for the
hypercube well thank you you know okay
anybody's help for that but you know
it's it's not a so a real the real
challenge is we have many many methods
for bounding rates of convergence of
Markov chains to their stationary
distributions I haven't been able to
figure out what coupling for a feature
is or anything like that and and I hope
somebody here can you can you say
something about the random set this be
four to six for the young for the train
Marty numbers which is one was for the
end random the bottom center at least on
an example would it be true that if I
pick a random set of half the size any
means there something like that known
for random said I I didn't try to do it
what I did notice if you you know
because it's it's so embarrassing to do
one example at a time it's natural to
try to do something like that I did
notice that if I took a set like the
square free numbers which had a density
like the multiples of three or a set
with the density where the the error in
the density was you know was reasonable
then it gets random after any finite
number of steps I haven't thought about
random sets
it's a perfectly you know what does a
typical set look like it I won't blame
you because you're my friend and bi it's
easy to blame myself but I fat find in
my life it's easy to make up questions
like that it is easy to make up
questions like that and then we study
them it's just been almost impossible to
take some real markov chain that
somebody runs and take a feature of
interest and say anything useful about
it and i think maybe it's better not to
get lost in what about this question
then let's try to do a real problem i'm
talking to myself now not you but I mean
it's no but I'll start working on it
squirting that's square hi Chris yep so
he can be next to the upper triangular
group you fruit to the lower Central
series This Is It this you good down the
central series things are facing faster
series presumably because they're
subject to the more and more complicated
conjugation actions by the things
something like that I don't I wasn't
able to make sense out of it so in order
to I mean I've tried so it's natural to
try to choose coordinates you know the
just so that you know if you can join in
our conversation the so the there's the
upper triangular group the the
commutator subgroup is all matrices
where the zero on the just above the
diagonal and so the quotient by the
commutator is just what's above the
diagonal the second commutator has zeros
in the first two column first two
diagonals and then store above it so but
the quotient by the second commutator is
both of those columns and so when I
tried to get my hands just on the second
column it's just take the center you
know I don't know a group theoretic way
of carrot getting my hands on the center
that so I don't I couldn't make sense
out of that Philip Hall had magic for
so-called regular p groups they were
very nice there's a very nice coordinate
system I couldn't blend
with this theory so it's not that it
couldn't be done I just I tried and
Emmanuel bright and Laurent tried and we
couldn't do it so we need another idea
bless you welcome so you hi yes sir
going vessel rich leading question so
for the journey k which sets of 13 cars
each pair received but there's nothing
you might wonder about which is if you
deal in one of these ways you receive
your car to get an order in which you
receive your cards might give you more
information about absolutely west south
south western and it has right
absolutely absolutely so it's a
wonderful question and i'll answer it in
the following way in bridge it's well
known by experts that you can watch
people sort their hand if somebody puts
a clump you know that's a clump of
hearts or something like that right and
so first of all people do that and there
are books that discuss it and the rules
of bridge forbid using any information
of that sort so it's against the law to
use the kind of thing you are thinking
about on the other hand if we all obeyed
the law that would be a very much a
better better world so there that is a
weakness of features is that I you know
it just when I look at the order of my
cards I can often tell things about the
order of the other cards it's worth
reminding people and you'll stop me but
you know you think does it actually make
a difference in maybe 30 years ago the
bridge world did a wonderful experiment
for us a natural experiment it used to
be that bridge was tournament bridge was
played with hand shuffle hands in 30
years ago it went to computer shuffled
hands and the group looked at a thousand
hands from tournament play and looked at
the suit distribution in the South hand
so that should be something like four
three three three or whatever it is and
they found that with hand shuffle hands
it's very flat many too many for three
three threes and very few 10 11 ones and
that's just overwhelming in the data
not some subtle you know chi squared is
you know is its point 05 it's you know
it's it's it's it's overwhelming in the
data why would it happen well in bridge
when I play clubs were all supposed to
play clubs roughly and if the cards get
grouped together in clumps of four and
if I'm looking out the window and
shuffling the cards they might still be
sort of a little bit clumped together
the club's sort of together and then
when I deal for hands they're too flat
okay so whether you like that story or
not it really is in the data and and so
it can it can make a difference in the
kind of thing that you're talking about
certainly makes a difference and I think
I learned is there are four journals
that you can currently subscribe to that
our card tracking journals shuffle
tracking journals and so people are
actually out there doing that with
people selling little computers and
trying to go in and the casinos say they
really are hurting them and that the
shuffle tracking so so people like us or
are trying to take advantage of these of
these flaws it's a the real world is
different than the world in this room
sorry so many questions by asking about
myself and another question so is it
surprising the lair of that shuttle just
had so much different from a regular
shuttle a male of reading that is to say
that all the lubricant shuffle is
nervous because it's it got this bizarre
event and it's kind of disturbing to
casino people I'm sure um other simple
variants riffle shut all i divided the
pack and do a random cut on one heart
and there will shuffle I mean is it
likely that something like this would
then mean that there was no difference
between the there and back in the
regular
well thank you I I hasn't you know I I
could as you know I could talk about
shuffling for many more than the weeks
allowed in this conference there there
when especially when people shuffle
large decks they exactly do stuff like
that and they also enter that won't help
so much but they also intermix strip
cuts like something like an overhand
shuffle and and so there's a whole
regimen of techniques that people use
and we have had a hard time analyzing
that we can analyze cuts and show that
cuts more or less don't matter straight
cuts doing them in between or anytime
but if you do something like what you
suggested it's harder Vita an asteroid
ian graham who are sitting over there
have done some work on the kind of
shuffle that you're suggesting for big
decks where you shuffle shuffle shuffle
ease you have them in groups of four and
then you transfer cards in some way
which is what people actually do when
they shuffle eight decks and so they're
starting to be some work geared to to
those problems but we kind of don't know
how to how to combine to Markov chains
which we know everything about that's
still a problem that I find challenging